the closer you get to
Victory the more aggressive the enemy
gets I've learned that the moment we
want to give up most is usually at the
dawn of our breakthrough we are right
there at the gate we just can't see it
it's a water of mind you got to see that
dream with your imagination so clear
that you bend reality around what you
want when a dreamer gets called stubborn
by the world he wears it proudly like a
badge of honor he knows that the ad
person should never understand what he's
doing why he's doing it nor should they
ever believe that it's possible for him
to achieve it the world's rejection and
unwavering resistance are his biggest
confirmation that he's on the right
track